欸，你聽說了嗎？有人用 AI 「組建」了一個七人行銷團隊，而且是一個人就搞定了，這點我真的覺得出乎意料。
嗯，我看到這篇報導了。七人團隊？聽起來是挺厲害的，但會不會只是把很多 AI 工具湊在一起，然後美其名曰「團隊」？實際運作上能跟真人團隊比嗎？
不完全是工具湊合。這篇文章的作者 Ben Angel 其實是先從一個痛點切入的。他說，即使 AI 可以幫你寫文案、剪影片、做圖，但如果每個環節還是要你親自選題、下指令、傳檔案、核稿，那你的行銷部門本質上還是你自己。
這點我同意。很多小企業主或個人創業者都有這種困擾，像 Constant Contact 在 2026 年第二季的報告就說，有 47% 的小企業主社群媒體行銷全部自己來。
對，所以 Ben Angel 的做法很有意思，他把 AI 不只當成工具，而是當成一個個有明確「職責」的「AI 代理人」。
怎麼說？「代理人」跟「工具」的差別在哪裡？
最大的不同是，他不是每次要 AI 幫忙都重新下指令，而是給每個 AI 一個「職位」，比如一個是負責 Reel 短影音剪輯的，一個負責市場研究，一個負責文案寫作，還有設計、排程、數據分析這些。
聽起來像是把一個真人行銷團隊的職位分拆給 AI 了。但這樣真的能做到「團隊協作」嗎？還是各做各的？
這就是厲害的地方。除了這些分工明確的 AI 代理人，他還設定了一個「行銷經理」AI 代理人。
行銷經理 AI？這點倒是讓我有點好奇了。這個經理 AI 怎麼管理其他 AI？
它負責協調。比如，它會把一個已經核准的文案丟給寫作 AI，寫好的文案再送給設計 AI，然後把表現數據回報給分析 AI。這樣整個行銷流程就能串起來。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說核准的文案，那誰來核准？總不會是 AI 自己核准吧？如果關鍵決策還是得人來做，那跟以前的差別是？
這是個好問題。原文強調，人類依然掌握關鍵的決策權。AI 代理人負責執行和協作，但像是內容的品質、行銷策略的走向，甚至最終的核准，還是由人來把關。
這樣聽起來，比較像是把重複性高、耗時的工作丟給 AI，讓人可以專注在策略和創意。這對資源有限的創業者或中小企業主來說，倒是一個不錯的思路。
沒錯。Ben Angel 在他的書《The Wolf Is at The Door》裡也提到，AI 助理應該要圍繞著人的知識、個性和溝通風格來建構，而不是讓人去適應 AI。
如果我是創業者，這會給我很大的啟發。以前覺得請不起這麼多人，行銷就只能自己硬著頭皮做。現在看來，只要架構規劃得好，用 AI 也能把行銷部門撐起來。
對一般上班族來說，我覺得這個概念也很有用。不一定是要組建一個團隊，但我們可以思考一下，工作中有哪些常規性、重複性高的任務，是不是也能拆解成不同「職責」交給 AI 處理。
比如，我自己常常要做會議記錄整理，如果能訓練一個 AI 代理人專門負責這個，把錄音檔餵給它，它就能自動整理出重點和待辦事項，那我可以省下很多時間。
是啊，而且這樣累積下來，AI 代理人的「技能」會越來越好，因為它會不斷根據你的指令、標準和修正來改進。
效果到底能不能持久，我覺得還有待觀察。但這個把 AI 從單純工具提升到「有職責的代理人」的思維，確實打開了一扇窗。
嗯，它好像也提醒了我們，未來的工作模式可能不再是「我」一個人做所有事，而是「我」帶領一群 AI 夥伴來一起完成。